so when you loan your friend money they
are no longer your friend you can't keep
that from happening they're your friend
is a secondary thing their primary
relationship is now slave and master
yeah the borrower is slave to the lender
when we went broke uh 30 plus years ago
uh Sharon's dad loaned us some money to
keep a car
and he's a kindest most saintly man
gentle you know we worked our way
through got it paid off and he he never
one time made us feel uncomfortable by
his actions or his attitudes but I can
tell you sitting at Thanksgiving dinner
felt different until I got that cleared
that's good because it's in the air it's
a slave master relationship you change
it